مهرجان شتاء طنطوره بدا لا احد يحتار الى
اين يذهب في العلا فعاليات ترفيهيه
وموسيقيه مواقع جديده بمطاعم ومقاهي فاخره
وبالطبع استكشاف الحضارات القديمه امر مهم
لجميع الزوار فهي بنا في رحله عبر الزمن
في عاصمه الممالك القديمه
[موسيقى]
استنشاق الهواء النقي بين الجبال خلال
الاقامه في العربات المتنقله امر ممتع
وهذا ما يتيحه مهرجان شتاء طنطوره
[موسيقى]
البلده القديمه في العلا اذا زرت هذا
المكان فانت محظوظ لان منظمه السياحه
العالميه اختارت البلده القديمه في العلا
كواحده من افضل الوجهات السياحيه في
العالم لعام 2022 هنا مقاهي على الطراز
القديم ومحال تجاريه تقدم هدايا للاصدقاء
والاقارب
[موسيقى]
بعد زياره دادان ومدائن صالح وجبل الفيل
والمناطق التاريخيه الاخرى في العلا يمكن
هنا للسياح الاستمتاع بتجربه ليليه فريده
من خلال التعرف اكثر على الفنون الشعبيه
لدى السعوديين من العلا نواف عزيز العربيه